so as you can see the honey here is
indefinite integrals last term we have a
look at all of the theory underneath
this we connected all of the the history
and the areas and calculus all together
in one big theoretical ball so now we
want to just get busy developing this
skill and fluency into doing integration
now one of the things that was really
clear when we were having a look at your
exam papers is that you are making the
error that generations of calculus
students have been making which is that
when it comes to powers you know how to
differentiate you know how to integrate
and it's super easy to confuse the two
so I'm thinking back to when I was your
age and one of the things I got taught
that helped me remember this a nice
little mnemonic device when it comes to
powers and I invite you to jot this down
with me it's really really simple to
remember integrals increase powers
that's why we say that index is going to
go up so if for example we were
integrating something like X to the
power of n whether that n was one two
three four or five or even four negative
numbers as we've seen except for
negative one what do we do there will we
increase the index we would write that
as X to the power of n plus one and then
we divide by that new power don't forget
we're dealing with indefinite integrals
here so you get that constant
integration flying on the end there let
me move this over because the fact that
it is not centered is bothering me okay
that's better
now you're probably anticipating what
the other side of the mnemonic is right
if integrals increase well conversely
derivatives decrease so for me when I
think back to you know all of the
different questions that I'm doing and
as you go further into the course you're
going to be asked to not just say hey
here's a differential calculus part of
the paper and here's an integral
calculus part of the paper you'll be
required to do these flexible and you'll
have to go in both direction directions
you have to seamlessly convert between
each so when you are differentiating if
you have this X ^ and we learnt this law
this rule much earlier we bring that
index down and then we reduce the index
by one so when you have a derivative the
powers decrease integrals increase do
Viv's decrease so hopefully that is nice
and memorable for you let's have a go at
some of the example questions in
exercise 1d we're going to do this in
two halves we'll look at some of the
simpler ones first I'll walk you through
invite some questions and then get you
to have a go at the the exercise and
then we will we'll break for probably
maybe 10 minutes in the middle or so
we'll see how we go for time and to let
you guys do some work independently and
then we'll return for the back half of
lesson to do some harder examples so
question 3b is the one that we're going
to tackle first and hopefully this is
one which you'll be able to call back
from last term that we can remember so
3b is right at the top here it says
varies directly find the following
indefinite integrals and there's Part B
there which we can all jot down together
the integral of x to the power 4 take
away X cubed DX so this is about as
straightforward as it gets the only
thing that needs to be worried about the
fact to you is that you've got two
different terms being integrated so we
just take them one at a time remembering
the integrals increase the power we're
going to go X to the power of 5 then we
divide by that new one that minus sign
hangs around for the ride and then we go
X to the power of 4 divided by 4 don't
forget your constant of integration so
that's not to be complicated nice firm
hands are very helpful screenshot there
let's have a look at the next question
down when we're seeing like I said this
applied to negative indices so question
forces find the indefinite integral of
each function and this one has said
leave negative indices in your answers
often the question will be provided to
you just as a fraction but they have
given us negative indices here so when
we take an integral here we're going to
leave the negative indices in place so
the example I want to have a go at was
for C so let me just put that interview
there there it is X to the power of
negative 8 so to find the indefinite
integral I'm going to go X to the power
of negative 8 and I'm integrating with
respect to X what am I going to do here
again integrals increase
those powers but the thing you need to
be careful for here's eight does it turn
into nine it's negative eight so it's
going to go up into negative seven so
I'm going to get here X to the power of
negative seven divided by that new index
which in this case was negative seven
now at this point you know I'm sort of
done I've done the integration but I
should tidy this up we don't tend to
like how do you having negative numbers
on our denominators so I'm just going to
do a minor adjustment there and put the
minus sign on top on the numerator so I
get X to the power of negative seven on
seven plus my constant and I'm only
leaving it in a negative index form just
because they've asked us to but if I
wanted to I could have written it as
negative one over seven X to the 7 plus
my constant in the tiny little space
that I have left over okay so let me
pause for a moment there and I'm gonna
ask you to have a look at question five
now five is a bit trickier in that again
we're not dealing with just nice easy
numbers I'm making it a little more
challenging for you here by throwing
fractions at you but it's the same
principle you can see here we're going
to be increasing the power still go up
by one just being really really careful
when you're dealing with those fractions
in Commons in on what is there so let me
give you 3060 seconds to have a go at
five D and five e and then I will show
you my answers so you're on the clock
have a go now I'm going to follow
something that I've been doing in the
past few lessons with you in that I'm
going to put an excessive amount of
working here mainly because it really
helps my brain to be able to check if
I'm doing this right and avoids common
errors so when I'm writing my integral
here actually I'm going to go straight
to actually I haven't integrated I'm
going to put this extra piece of work in
here plus one up the top there to really
indicate to myself there's the n plus
one you might be able to guess what the
common error here is people see two over
three they look at the two and they say
well I'm just gonna add one to that and
it becomes three over three but you're
not increasing the index by one there
you're only increasing it by a third so
once I've got that I'm going to divide
by this new power which is 2/3 plus one
I've got my constant now
and what that allows me to do is to
separate in my brain the two processes
happening at the same time I'm doing the
integration which is the +1 and divide
by the new index and now separately I'm
gonna deal with the fractions um 2/3
plus 1 that's 2/3 plus 3/3 so that's
gonna give me X to the power of 5 on 3 &
5 on 3 is the same thing that appears on
the denominator now I'm gonna sneak this
down a little bit to give me some extra
space to do the tidying up here when I
look at this division by 5/3 it's messy
right just like we don't like to have
negative numbers on our denominators we
don't tend to like fractions on our
denominators either if we can avoid it
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take
that fraction the whole thing X to the
5/3 divided by 5/3 I'm gonna put some
brackets there just to make it very very
clear I'm gonna multiply the numerator
and the denominator by 3 so that gives
me 3
whoopsie-daisy 3 X to the 5/3 on the top
and it's going to give me a 5 on the
denominator because the 3 is canceled
like I said it's actually quite fine and
in fact if I were in a hurry and and I
was in exam because I'm fairly
comfortable with this I would probably
go straight to this line of working if I
were trying to do this in the most
efficient way possible I just know my
brain and fractions especially when I'm
under time pressure
I'm very liable to make mistakes here
and it's a little bit I mean it's the
same thing as you know rubbing your
tummy and patting your head it's just
your brain gets confused between the two
thing is trying to do and I will often
forget to do one of them entirely and
then you wonder how do I make that
ceiling mistake alright let's have a go
with this one again I'm going to put an
extra line of working in so I've got X
to the power of negative 1/2 and I'm
gonna add 1 to that and then I divide
that by whatever that result will be add
my constant integration my integration
is done now but I'm going to tidy up all
of these fractions here 1/2 sorry
negative 1/2 plus 1 can you all tell me
what that is in the comments you should
be able to type that in it's not too
complicated
I'll even take it as a decimal if you
like okay fantastic seeing the first few
ones come through wonderful hums have
you already gone to the next step that's
great
so yes I'm going to get a negative 1/2
plus one so that's just 1/2 and then I'm
dividing by that same thing plus 1/2 but
of course division by a fraction is the
same as multiplication by the reciprocal
so that's why you get 2x to the 1/2 plus
C now the question here again is said
leave fractional indices in your answers
but if we didn't what does X to the
power of 1/2 actually indicate that it's
going to be a square root isn't it so
you could also write this as 2 square
root of x plus C today's I didn't mean
to call that all right now the last one
we're gonna have a go at together just
before I set you loose to do a few more
of those other questions is 6f now it
says and it gets very specific here by
expanding brackets where necessary find
the following indefinite integrals and
here's f in case you don't have the
questions open up there in front of you
so 6 F let's move this guy out of the
way for a moment so that I can use this
I always forget how much working space I
actually need so 6 F is asking us to
integrate 2x plus 1 all squared with
respect to X now there is another way to
do this which we'll come to in the
second half of this lesson but we're not
going to do that quite yeah 2x plus 1
all squared let's do the expansion here
carefully first term second term and
then we'll double the product so 2x all
square that looks to me like it's going
to be whoopsie-daisy and in my integral
sign that looks like it's going to be 4x
squared my second term being squared
there 1 squared is 1 and then you're
also going to get double of the product
so 1 times 2x gives you 2x double it
gives you 4x now I haven't done any
integration yet I've just messed with
that thing being integrated VM the
integrand if you want to use the fancy
term there that's the name of let's do
it this way
there we go that thing in there
is the integrand so by making that
expanded we can now go through turn my
term and do this just like the other
questions we were doing this time now
they think we've got a hang of it I'm
going to do it a little more quickly so
I'm going to get that 4x cubed on 3 the
integral increase the index plus X plus
now this guy here will become 4x squared
on 2 but hopefully you're seeing there
or that 2 and therefore we're going to
cancel leaving me with 2x squared plus
my constant like